[Music]
[Music]
this is the scene of the crime
a crime of passion filmed in a way you
have never seen before
and as no one else would dare attempt
but the screen's master of suspense
the producer director who shocked the
world with psycho
this is the apartment of a man named
jefferies a news photographer whose beat
used to be the world
right now his world has shrunk down to
the size of this window
he's been watching the people across the
way nobody seems to pull their blinds
during a hot spell like this
he knows a lot about them by now too
much perhaps
for instance down there on the second
floor the woman pacing about
he calls her miss lonely hearts so
lonely that even death
seems like a friend these are the
newlyweds on a honeymoon
no one will ever forget
he calls her miss hearing aid an artist
of a very odd and strange art
the songwriter who plays the same melody
over and over again
a genius or insane
this is the traveling salesman and his
invalid wife
out of their arguments and nagging comes
a weird kind of love
miss torso the body beautiful that is
viewed from a safe distance
those are just a few of my neighbors
first i watch them just to kill time
but then i couldn't take my eyes off
them just as you won't be able to
and you won't be able to take your eyes
off the glowing beauty of grace kelly
who shares the heart and curiosity of
james stewart
in this story of a romance shadow by the
terror of a horrifying secret
[Music]
good afternoon
here we have a quiet little motel
tucked away off the main highway
and as you see perfectly harmless
looking
when in fact it has now become
known as the scene of the crime
this motel also has as an adjunct
an old house
which is if i may say so
a little more sinister looking less
innocent than the motel itself
and in this house the most dire
horrible events took place
i think we can go inside because the
place is up for sale
although i don't know who's gonna buy it
now
in that window on the second floor the
single one in front
that's where the woman was first seen
[Music]
let's go inside
[Music]
you see even in daylight this place
still looks a bit sinister
now it was at the top of these stairs
but the second murder took place she
came
out of the door there and met the victim
at the top
of course in a flash there was the knife
and in no time
the victim tumbled and fell with a
horrible crash i think the back broke
immediately it hit the floor
it was it's difficult to describe the
way that the the
twisting of the of the well
i won't dwell upon it come upstairs
of course the victim or should i say
victims
hadn't any conception as to the type of
people they would be confronted with in
this house
especially the woman she was the
weirdest and the most
well let's go into her bedroom
[Music]
here's the woman's room still
beautifully preserved
and the imprint of her figure on the
bait where she used to lay
i think some of her clothes are still in
this wardrobe
[Music]
bathroom
[Music]
this was the sun's room but uh we won't
go in there
because his favorite spot was the little
parlor behind his office in the motel
let's go down there
[Music]
this young man you had to feel sorry for
him
after all being dominated by an almost
maniacal woman
was enough to drive anyone to the
extreme of uh
well let's go in
well i suppose you'd call this his
hideaway
his hobby as you see was taxidermy
crow here an owl there
an important scene took place in this
room there was a private
supper here and
oh by the way this picture
has great significance
because
uh let's go along to cabin number one
i want to show you something there
[Music]
all tied it up
[Music]
the bathroom
well they've cleaned all this up now
big difference you should have seen the
blood
the whole the whole place was well it's
it's too horrible to describe dreadful
and i'll tell you there's a very
important clue was found here
down there
well the murderer you see crept
in here very slowly of course the shower
was on there was
no sound and
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the new york times called it tingly with
excitement
the detroit news said it's the best
crime play in years
the london daily mail headlined a murder
thriller with a difference
the new york daily mirror wrote it holds
your attention like a vice
where's the nearest police station what
could you tell them
i should simply tell them that you're
trying to blackmail me into
into murdering your wife
fantastic isn't it but you know he's
right don't you tony
you've worked it out to the smallest
detail and this man
is to be your murder weapon for the
perfect crime
and you margo you've been living
dangerously
too dangerously a married woman with a
two-party line to your affections and
mark
ironic isn't it that in this design for
death
you should be selected to be the perfect
alibi
for the murder of the woman you love are
you ever gonna tell tony
about us no i couldn't possibly tell him
not now there is evidence however that
he was blackmailing you
blackmail yes i'm afraid it's true tony
and you suggest that he came in by the
window
and we know that he came in by that door
but he can't have come in that way that
door was locked
you could have let him in
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm an advertising man not a red herring
i've got a job a secretary
a mother two ex-wives and several
bartenders depended upon me
and i don't intend to disappoint them
all by getting myself slightly killed
you can't fight it carrie someone's out
to get you by violence
or by abduction they'll even frame you
for murder
so run for your life search for a man
who doesn't exist
a secret nobody knows and start a love
affair in an upper
hello there tell me why are you so
good to me shall i climb up and tell you
why
a train may be an old-fashioned way to
make a getaway
but who wants to get away from an
exquisite inquisitive blonde
how do i know you aren't a murderer you
don't
even marie saint seems to enjoy carrie's
romantic performance
but her companion james mason has other
ideas
ask him carrie apparently the only
performance that will satisfy you is
when i play
dead in your very next role you'll be
quite convincing i assure you
[Music]
then supplies after another adventurous
carry romanced by the kind of blonde
that gets into a man's blood
even if she has to shoot her way in
[Music]
two fellows meet like you and i no
connection between them whatsoever
each one has somebody that he'd like to
get rid of
so they swap murders
fantastic isn't it you didn't know when
bruno proposed this pact that he was
serious
dead serious you had made the mistake of
speaking to a stranger on a train
and now wherever you go whatever you do
you find yourself dominated by his evil
presence
and you bruno to you killing was the
answer
murder without clue without motive the
perfect crime
and then life looked very attractive to
you
until the love in your heart became
gripped by a terror that drew you deeper
and deeper
into this vortex of conspiracy
i don't like to be double-crossed
i have a murder on my conscience but
it's not my murder mr haynes
i wonder if you know how much i love you
brazen woman
change
[Music]
cary grant and this year's academy award
winner grace kelly
two exciting personalities who were made
for each other
and now alfred hitchcock brings them
into very close contact in this perfect
tale of romantic entry
filmed on the beautiful french riviera
very strong grip the kind of burglar
[Music]
needs
that's why you came out here isn't it
the scandalous romance that shocked even
the blase
international set between this restless
thrill-hunting american heiress
and the notorious man of mystery the
french underworld called the
cat or the game they played was not
played for money
and the characters they played with
played for keeps
no one but hitchcock could create such
relentless excitement
filling the screen with fireworks as he
matches the blazing talents of these two
great stars
in the love affair of the year
[Music]
look john hold them
diamonds have you ever had a better
offer in your whole life
one with everything
come down robbie we shall be forced to
shoot
[Music]
how do you do my name is alfred
hitchcock
and i would like to tell you about my
forthcoming lecture
it is about the birds and their age-long
relationship with men
it will be seen in theaters like this
across the country in my lecture i hope
to make you
all aware of our good friends the birds
theirs is a noble history and through it
all man has played a conspicuous part
this cave drawing is one of man's
earliest sketches of his feathered
friend
one can see at once the loving care
with which the artist depicted his
subject
[Music]
the story of man and his friends the
birds
is filled with many fine examples of
ways
in which these noble creatures have
added to the beauty of the world
take this plumed hat from the period of
charles the first
how proud the birds must have been to
have their feathers
plucked out to brighton man's drab
life here we have a later model
a refinement of the first here man
or rather woman thought enough of the
birds to have an entire one
as a decoration it's quite dead of
course
naturally the egg plays a very prominent
part in my lecture
not a word about which came first
however i don't believe
in dealing with controversial matters
thousands of years ago
man was satisfied merely to steal an egg
from a nest
and use it for food now he has perfected
this process
by imprisoning each hand in a separate
cage
and by scientifically manipulating the
lights so that she doesn't fall into the
rut of the old 24-hour day
thus he can induce the bird to reach
fantastic heights of egg production
originally there were many varieties of
birds on earth
some have become extinct the great orc
the passenger pigeon and the famous dodo
bird have all disappeared
actually they didn't exactly disappear
they were simply
killed off but of course this is
nature's way
man merely hurries the process along
whenever he can be of help
man and birds have been responsible for
a great many advances in our
civilization
for example the bird was the inspiration
for the invention of gun
powder and it was his speed that brought
about the development
of the shotgun but man has not been
unmindful of his debt to the bird
we have honored our feathered friends in
many ways we cage
birds and show them off proudly in most
of our zoos
and the turkey is traditionally our
guest of honor of thanksgiving
i suspect you never realize that if it
weren't for birds even some of our
pastimes
would suffer noticeably duck hunting for
example
granted bagging a fellow hunter can be
diverting
but the supply is rather limited
i hope you don't mind if i have
something to eat
but i'm rushed today planning the
lecture has been most educational for me
i've begun to feel very close to the
birds and have developed a real sympathy
for our little
what was i saying oh yes i've come to
feel very
close to the birds and have come to
realize how they feel when
i don't think i'll eat just now hardly
proper with all of you here
surely the birds appreciate all we've
done for them
don't you beautiful cage fresh water
no other birds to bother you none of
that blinding sunlight
oh now why would he do that
most peculiar
they're coming they're coming
[Applause]
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen this is
johnny jones the globe syndicate
speaking to you from amsterdam holland
where i've been an eyewitness to the
assassination of the dutch cabinet
minister vanmir the key figure of
european politics
an hour ago i arrived from london by
plane to meet van meer
as i waited for him on the steps of the
peace palace he lighted from his car and
made his way toward me
halfway he was stopped by a news
photographer who asked for a picture
then they're consented and was shot dead
by a revolver held close to the
photographer's camera
bystanders rushed to van meer's aid and
i pursued the assassin through the crowd
only to lose him in traffic
follow that car wait
say you better get out of here this
might be dangerous trouble
assassinated looked like it
i can't see hey yeah yeah
there you are me boy oh
i'm afraid you'll have to keep the
builder much longer than we planned but
that's absolutely impossible
i think you better keep the girl after
the rest of the night
well i can't very well explain but i
simply couldn't pull a thing like that
you know how much i loved you you'd
faint
[Music]
lorraine dave herbert marshall
george sanders albert basserman robert
[Music]
vertigo a feeling of dizziness a
swimming in the head
figuratively a state in which all things
seem to be engulfed in a whirlpool of
terror
as created by alfred hitchcock in the
story that gives new meaning to the word
suspense
[Music]
i don't want to die there's someone
inside me she says i must die
a beautiful girl haunted by the
desperate unexplainable urge to destroy
herself
a man possessed by the paralyzing
vertigo that made him afraid of high
places
easy now oh oh no
ah where's the cinch there i look up
i look down i look up i look
[Applause]
what was the strange attraction that
brought these two together in spite of
the dark forces that tore them apart
the specter from the past that drew her
to the ancient headstone in the mission
graveyard
the compulsion that drove her
relentlessly to the point of no return
the story of a love so powerful it broke
down all barriers between past and
present
between life and death between the
golden girl in the dark tower
and the tawdry redhead that he tried to
remake in her image
if i let you change me will that do it
if i do what you tell me
would you love me yes all right
then i'll do it but i don't care anymore
about me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you